for an inside perspective on the
situation at lufthansa we're joined by
jerk handwek he's the press spokesman of
germany's pilots union cockpit
thanks for joining us
first of all i read that one day after
the crash a german wings pilot greeted
all the passengers on board personally
by handshake he told them about his
family at home saying he would do
everything to get back to them safely
his words were much appreciated everyone
on board applauded so clearly many
people now travel with mixed feelings
including pilots and flight attendants i
should think how do you cope
well it was a great shock for us as well
as for the passengers so
we need time to move on and especially
in the beginning
it was
there's a certain distrust of the
passengers
to the pilots to the cabin stuff of
course now and uh we have to cope with
that we have to show us us as a person
it's easier to trust somebody if you can
see who it is instead just hearing the
voice yeah meeting them personally being
able to look them into the eyes that
might help now the airlines have also
reacted already what's your take on how
they did it introducing the two persons
cockpit rule for example will that help
we think
it's about trust right now trust of the
passengers into the airlines into the
pilots
and therefore we said it's a good
measure for right now but in the long
run we have to think of
if it's really the best uh thing we can
do because
stewardess has very limited capabilities
of understanding what we do in the
cockpit and she has very limited uh
influence on our flight so if a pilot
wants to crash the plane uh she cannot
really do much about it just open the
door yeah or if there's another
emergency if the if the pilot feels ill
or whatever then at least somebody would
be there to do something about it
hopefully what about the um
psychological aspect there's a lot of
talk about taking psychological tests
when do you know that you're fit to fly
when do you
when are you not fit to fly
well it's a very hot debate in germany
right now about psychological tests but
uh
we had these discussions uh
within the pilot community
uh several years ago and from time to
time we have it again and
always the psychologist told us
it's not really of a great value
because today you can feel fantastic and
the next day one of your relatives dies
your partner leaves you and you're in a
deep crisis so
it's not really high value to have an
examination a week ago
now
as an air traveler myself i was very
much aware that the pilot's union has
had an ongoing dispute with lufthansa
over the airline's pension scheme uh
other air trial travelers like myself
we've been feeling the pinch in recent
months do you think that this tragedy
will fuel the route further
i think it's too early and there's no
real connection between our terrorist
struggle with the company and this
horrible accident so
i think it's too early to say
what will change uh between the pilots
and the management right well jack
handwek press spokesman of germany's
pilots union cockpit thank you so much
for taking the time and speak to us
you're welcome